somehow people are still gonna say John
is a lot sexier than Greg well I'm
representing with my roosterteeth
clothes John is gonna be playing with
his hair we're gonna watch the honest
trailer for birds of prey - smash
box-office hit from the DC Universe
before we roll on in to this reaction
guys I did want to mention you've
probably heard us mention this before
but it's important that I ream engined
at the mention of the mentions download
and follow us on the Stardust app
30-second reviews for any film TV show
and/or a trailer we are posting quite a
lot within this quarantine situation we
are catching up on so many different
random things I think you'll find it
quite rewarding you can post your own
content there as well the whole thing is
free to download free to use we're not
being paid to mention this but we are
using it do it today
it's fun follow us first are you stuck
indoors like the rest of us wondering
how you can help click the link below
yes john bailey relief they provide
personal protective equipment and
essential medical items to health
workers responding to corona virus
please do your part and give what you
can
ok
sure in a world where Warner Brothers
wishes Jared Leto never existed in fact
we're all Suicide Squad will I forget it
ever happened
the one part you liked about the film
has been plucked from an early grave and
given her own squad just don't let her
do the tattoos deciding a woods of prey
a new finally Quint eventually that
movie me that sandwich look good have to
prove than just a lady Joker
so she's forming your own criminal gang
but not taking it seriously while
cracking jokes in clown makeup and using
goofy weapons to fight a rich guy
dressed in black this doesn't really
seem like much of an emancipation to me
more of a sparkly do-over that's not
very scrumptious lesson not even web SS
have you asked me explore Gotham City
like you've never seen it before in the
daylight
that's ready to conquer it all there's a
homicidal trust-fund kid in blackface I
mean white man's like this I got it when
I was embedded with the abandoned congo
kinshasa you and Loretta Jones as the
owner of the world's worst Club to hang
out at get on now
whoo-hoo Boyd's the mud to Gotham club
man Tuesday Angela's gay enough to hope
it slides past the censors in China
contracts contracts because he's
different than the guy in the comics
really looking forward to hearing about
this and the Mandarin until the Sun
expire finale we're gonna have to work
together there we go
there's Huntress a realistic portrayal
of that awkward in orbit and trained to
become a murderer Cassandra Cain a kid
alive boy Renee Montoya a cop with a
special power to okay she's just a car
and quite canary she sings really loud
and kicks good and stuff in these ladies
I only know four things about katana one
two three I would advise not getting
killed by her and her sword tribes the
souls of its victims easy does not
Stanford develop characters so Sudan
bird yes
I okay awesome fight sequences to make
this Hot Topic version of Beyonce's
lemonade your inner teenager but since
it's rated R for no good reason went
unseen by actual teenagers without
[Laughter]
[Music]
always da baby dr. Marvin Kendall income
taxes whoa Carly doesn't pay taxes and
voted for Bernie no that's some Joker
stuff thanks for watching and once again
has really sharp honest really yeah very
sharp honest really wash your hands with
great mustache at CGI I saw a tiger and
the tiger saw a man yes I love when they
let John Bailey let loose and I'm gonna
do some impersonations and accents and
whatnot it's always great Manson town -
voiceover artists I should reply to his
text he texted me about Artemis Fowl go
ahead listen I just remembered I haven't
replied yet John Bailey if you're
watching this I am sorry I will wait for
your comment on this video then I will
be like haha he has realized that I have
realized that I have forgotten good job
again team honest trailers writers and
editors and everyone's working from home
right now so can imagine the transfer
upload speed that you guys are do you
think with at the moment to get this on
his trailer off the ground
but I thought this was a really sharp
well written and well conceived on his
trailer we're two of the people on the
internet who actually enjoyed birds of
prey actually I believe Dan Merlin Roth
cornet it like the movie to see see
we're not doing up we're not the only we
have to like this film I don't know how
this film is performing though if it's
doing better on video on demand I'm just
waiting for the blu-ray to come out
because I'm going to buy it and I really
do like the movie and I I do got a
comment to make about what they were
saying I thought that they might do the
way the you know audiences might react
the whole black mass portrayal being
wildly different and while there are
people who have complained how I've even
heard people I remember when we watched
Joker there was someone named names I'll
let her speak for herself but there was
someone who was in the theater who I
didn't realize was going to the movie
she hated the way Joker was portrayed
walking in Phoenix's portrayal because
it's not really in tune with the comics
so some people just really have a hard
time adapting or readjusting to a
different board trail but I think the
main difference with black mask versus
Mandarin and the why I don't think the
reaction has been as heavily criticized
is because black mask the portrayal up
front is clearly different whereas
there's a switcheroo with Mandarin where
it's like oh we're getting the Mandarin
we've always wanted yes spanked
Kingsley's delivering and I'm like
towards the finale they you know pull a
switcheroo that I grew to appreciate
over time but in the immediate moment I
was part of that hate I really was
loathing that so I think people were not
as dismayed by this black mass portrayal
maybe a pond like trailers and stuff and
maybe there's a hardcore comics fans who
didn't like it but I think most people
were like yeah it's a different
portrayal I'm able to accept it more and
also not as many people watch this movie
yeah I feel like people may be inclined
to be more lenient about black masks a
because I'm sure that the average
audience probably has a little less of
some of that knowledge than say like a
character like the Joker or one of the
top villains and so it's not like Lex
Luthor and BBS where it's like obviously
this character is not the character at
all no and also I mean not that a great
performance always salvages
spiritual shift but you know you've got
two great performances in human McGregor
and in the guy who plays Victor Zsasz
whose name I've lit Chris Maloney no
Melanie Molina mussina mussina coming
back to Law & Order but yeah I think
also because Victor Zsasz was pretty on
point sure I think there's also that
that could maybe help with that yeah
that's fair that's fair
and also I thought we got to know the
birds of prey
reasonably well definitely better than
suicide squad yeah I mean I know they're
just making a joke they're doing it's
honest trailers did they make a crack
other than the fact that they didn't
want to read the title of fabulous
emancipation did they make a joke in
here about how the theaters change the
title a week after release to try to get
more people in the seats too late way
too late yeah yeah and that was another
thing too it's like we talked about in
our review I think we were all prepped
because of the marketing that it wasn't
gonna be really a birds-of-prey movie
more of a Harley Quinn film that being
said there were times over especially
huntress I would forget that she's
supposed to be in the movie yeah yeah
yeah and I kind of go back and forth
because it's like we did all kind of get
the idea that this is gonna be the
Harley Quinn movie and I don't begrudge
them the fact that the movie does by the
end of it take disparate parts and
assemble a team out of it so it's not
perhaps the the most on point birds of
prey origin story but it still gets an
origin story in there yeah that's
probably my one criticism that we
actually didn't really dive into is that
by the time they form the team the birds
of prey it sort of felt like we we have
to have them form a team because it's
birds of prey mmm you know it didn't
feel as built up to that moment or truly
earned or felt it's like yeah it makes
sense and I'm buying it because this
birds of prey but at the same time by
the time I get there it feels a little
bit like we got a doctor this in the
spring place yeah oh yeah oh yeah cuz
the way the movie plays out it feels
like they definitely banded together and
did some heavy but I don't leave the
movie necessarily thinking all these
people are gonna team up and spend all
their time together you know all that
being said I still stand by this film I
thought it was a total blast I wish more
people saw it and I'm hoping that over
time ik develops more of a following I
just think it was i rewatch Joker last
week actually we shot a trailers
revisited for it
really put me in the mood to watch the
movie I really think that this should
not have been the film following Joker
true that yeah yeah I think that was a
big no-no on there and yeah totally
should have been something in between
especially with Harley Quinn and the
fact that you do elude is you mean in
the trailer to Jared Leto's Joker that
could have been more of an it's like now
we're moving past that j.lo Joker world
the one with the Suicide Squad so I
think it could have been more exciting
if you had a film in between and then
you brought Harley Quinn back under cut
this is my personal opinion they should
just put the Snyder cut out right after
Joker sure alright guys well birds of
prey have you given it a second chance
that you avoid it at the theatres have
you seen it on video and a man have been
like you know what those actually better
than I thought
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to honest trailers subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification bell
falls in the Stardust app and last but
not least let's end this with a Maria
Haman been pledged to our patreon page
for a little bit recently ups her pledge
to get a shout out managed to get in
that slot so I cooked you up a Greg poem
her name is Maria holier than Mother
Teresa worshiped by many in a crowded
arena some say her name means Lady of
the sea so set your sail long course and
be free she discovered me on movie
fights and then spent so many nights
wishing she could take a bite out of
this dark night movies okay of course
miss Hammond
that's just my ego assuming of what
you're hoping would happen not just a
fan of Greg Alba she's also a fan of
John Roca
well now I'm hoping Roca gets Corona cuz
I don't want to share you don't tell him
I said that because he will send me a
text and he knows my address and he just
leaves me feeling distressed
I know lately you've had to have surgery
I hope your recovery is going smoothly
before the short poem is done I wanted
to say something to your son his name is
Joshua he is your hero like you I
academia Joshua I believe in you it'd be
a great contributor to America run up
rocky stairs in Philadelphia surf the
beaches of California your future will
be seen in the stars through the lens at
a planet area those are the closest
words I could think of to make sense
week
rhymin Joshua we're done